Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and today my name is
Alisa Faith Pennington and I am a u s
citizen by birth. We're going to start,
I was homeschooled my entire
life with a cry for help.
I have no 19 years old and I'm unable
to get a driver's license, get a job,
go to college, get on a plane,
get a bank account for vote.
This is the story of a woman
who became sort of famous.
I didn't pick the situation for
myself and I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know how to get this
through being invisible.
So
for having no identity whatsoever,
if you've been through a similar
situation or know anyone who can help,
please contact me. The story
comes to us from our reporter,
Alexandra young and the young
woman at the center of this story.
Um, I was born in Texas is Elisia faith.
Pennington goes by faith
in, born in Houston.
And then we moved to Kerrville.
Uh, when I was real little,
like I don't even remember Houston at
all. She grew up in a really small town.
About 45 minutes outside of San
Antonio and it's kind of country.
We lived right outside
of Kerrville actually.
So it was even more in the
country than Kerrville. His face.
Parents were very
conservative, very religious,
and they had created a place for their
family that was separate from the rest of
the world.
Well, hi there. Welcome
to the Pennington point.
I'm Lisa and I just wanted to
say a quick hello face mom.
Lisa actually kept a video blog
of life in the Pennington family.
Right now the sun is shining,
the birds are singing so
peaceful out here in the country.
So we had like maybe like five acres
of land. This is our front porch.
We bought this old farm house
about 10 years ago and started
and we had a little home
farm. We had goats, chickens.
We had um, rabbits at one point,
a cow that we would like raise,
you know,
we'd butcher it and then freeze like all
the meat and then eat it over the year.
So it was this sort of approaching
self-sufficiency or was it, was it,
I think what my parents wanted to do
is kind of reach that self-sufficient
point. Um, but they also really
wanted to give their something,
their kids to teach them
responsibility every day before he
could go play. You had to do a chore.
There was a chore.
We had a chart and it would have the
kids names down one. How many of those,
how many of you were there? But
nine children, grace, Jacob hope,
faith patients don't. Adam a legend,
Levi. Um, you've got that down pat
picking loader forth right in the
middle, Middle Child Syndrome.
And her parents says
faith. They were kind,
but I'm very firm, very strict.
A lot of rules for how you're supposed
to dress and how you're supposed to look
and how you supposed to carry yourself.
What were some of those rules? Uh,
for the girls? Um,
you had to wear dresses and little super
high callers and we always had to wear
sleeves. No sleeveless, kinda Amish
but not like that conservative. And uh,
we all had really, really long hair.
We didn't cut our hair and we just didn't
have a lot of access to things that
they didn't want us to have access to.
Like we didn't have internet until like,
you were like 18 and could get on the
allowed on the Internet for like limited
sites and stuff. What about
television? Did you guys have that? No.
None of kids watch television today.
Um, love electronics then they don't,
they tend to not have as much of a
passion for learning and working and um,
their bottle reading and they didn't
get to watch a lot of movies growing up.
They only listen to Christian music.
Were you homeschooled or were you,
did you go to public school
or what? How did that work?
All homeschool DePaul school. Every
single one. What does that mean?
That you were like, I'm always on the,
on the property or we need a go to
church off and on various times.
So we'd go off for that because stuff
but just sort of super rarely like we
didn't most of the time Trisha,
mostly you are with your family.
Then I was just having a kind of a moral
thing like like we are trying to keep
you a wholly and I think they just
wanted to keep like the things that they
thought were like sinful in the world
away from their kids and try to like keep
them safe and everything. But they
stopped that. So if you said I want yes,
they would say no and they when they
say nope. Yeah, arguing was not allowed.
But faith actually she was always just
kind of pushing that line just the little
bit. I am definitely a lot more stubborn
and a lot more free spirited and right
around her 18th birthday
I just, I don't know,
I reached a point like a breaking point.
Mm.
Was,
we were actually having like a little
family meeting and I was with the four
oldest siblings and my parents were
kind of supposed to discuss things.
And then my oldest sister
asked was asking my mom,
she was considering getting a job and
kind of asking advice or permission if she
could. And they're like, nope, that
brings in too much outside influence.
But she was 23 yeah. Hmm.
And then my brother said he wanted more
internet because he was doing work for
our church and they're like, I'm
sorry we can't do that. You know,
you could be looking at
things online, you know,
we just have to shut it off then
hope the one that's right next to me,
she was 21 she was asking for a
phone. My own parents were like, no,
you don't have to have a phone. And
so I was just like, wow. You know,
I'm looking at my other siblings
and they have nothing ahead of
them. We're not allowed to get jobs,
not allowed to go to school.
They have no life except living here on
this little farm. They have no future.
After that night, I decided I
couldn't live like that. I couldn't,
I was not going to turn out like that.
So I had an iPod and I went down
to my parent's room and I snuck,
um,
when my mom wasn't there and I snuck my
grandpa's phone number and since he had
an iPhone, I could text him over Wifi
from my iPod. So I did. And I said, hey,
when y'all come visit next weekend,
I want to go back with you.
I need help. Like I need
to go away from here.
Can you take me back home with
you? And um, he said he would.
So grandpa is not of the
same mind as your folks? Oh,
well
they weren't really on board
with how my parents did things,
but they always kept coming to see us and
so I knew that they cared about me and
so I felt safe to reach out to them.
So the next week her grandpa and her
grandma show up at the farm and um,
Yep.
Plan was to just, you know, just
what were you going to bolt or
how are you going to do this?
I went into bold. Yeah, no, but I just
wanted to go, but my grandpa was like,
you need to ask them first. You
need to ask permission. So I did.
And then they said, no, you can't go
with them. And then so I was like,
okay, cause I couldn't
argue. And then I said,
uh, or they approached my
grandparents approached me back,
so do you still want to go or,
and I finally decided that I did.
As far as you know,
you're the only one so far in the family
history that might dare to act on this,
these convictions.
Uh, no one had ever done anything
like that in our family before.
So
the next morning, September 24th,
2014 my mom was on her morning
run and my dad was in his office.
He said he was always there
working in the morning,
so none of them were in the house and my
grandparents had goodbye to the rest of
the kids. Then I just walked
out the door with them.
With luggage or just one suitcase? Yeah,
my, my grandpa texted my mom and was
like, we're taking faith with us.
Just wanted you to know. And
then my mom texted him and said,
don't go anywhere yet. I'm coming back.
She had texted my dad and then
they, they both came and, uh,
tried to get me to get out
of the car. They were like,
you have to get out of the car. I was
like, I don't have to like, well, yeah,
you have to because we're telling
you to. I'm like, well, no.
So they got in and they actually
asked my grandparents to get out.
They were like,
can you get out of the car and
we'll get in so we can talk to her.
So you were alone in the car with your
parents then? That's when all the,
all the safety goes away right here.
That's the only thing I had on my side
is that I was buckled in the car and
refused to get out. I think
they were just kind of shocked.
I was so torn. I mean, they
felt like I was just melting.
And what was it that
kept you in the seat? Um,
I think it was just telling myself over
and over that I knew it was the right
thing to do, even though
it doesn't feel like it.
I had to take control of my
life and after awhile they,
my grandparents were like, we have
to go, like we need to leave now.
And so they left just drove away.
[inaudible]
so these were like, this is, this is what,
eight people that you eight plus two,
so this is 10 people that you are,
yeah, they're my entire world. Like yeah,
I was astonished that she had the
boldness to carry out that plan.
This is Jenny Elena's
face and her mother's,
who like her grandparents didn't really
subscribe to the Pennington Worldview,
but she would visit them from time to
time at the farm. You know, for faith,
it's even more than just the
boldness of leaving her family.
She believed she was walking
into this world that was bad,
that was potentially going to harm her.
[inaudible]
so that first night she gets to my
parents' house, my grandparents said, hey,
you can sleep in this room and
there's a TV in the guest room.
And they just toss a remote
and leave her alone and said,
we want whatever you want. Now faith,
she had never been allowed to pick
her own TV shows. No. And so she,
she turns it on
for a place that gets full sun and she
said it was like a eight to 10 hours of
sunlight a day gardening show or a
home improvement show or something.
And she's sitting there thinking, I
don't know if this is bad for me exactly.
Just pour a little water on
top and if it drains away,
should I be watching this? Cause that's
kind of what my parents did there.
They would kind of dictate what
was right, was wrong. You know,
when someone would do something, but
okay, that's wrong. We're like, okay,
that's right. And now that
moral compass was gone,
she suddenly wasn't sure what was
good and what was bad anymore. Yeah.
I am so tired of the way
we relate to one another.
And 19 is a tough place
to step into the world.
Being that naive to have sex
with his wife, I don't care.
You know, she was asking me about sex,
like how do you learn? What do you,
I don't know anything. I thought
I knew what kind of manual.
I didn't know anything. Even
the most basic social norms,
like I don't know how I'm supposed to act
when she'd hang out with her cousin or
other people her own age. I don't
know what I'm supposed to talk about.
I didn't catch mostly like the references
I'd make all these other teenagers
would be talking about shows, boys
music, movies, school in faith.
I had no idea
she wanted to join this
world. We all live in.
I mean even in the most simple ways. She
wanted to get a job and learn to drive,
have an apartment, but she couldn't,
she didn't have course have
a driver's license. Nope.
Plus she didn't have a
social security number.
Didn't have the birth certificate?
No. Where you were born. We did.
When you were born, didn't they say, okay,
this is the hospital will
wasn't at a hospital.
It was all home birth plus
they specifically sought
out midwives that would
agree to file no records. Why
would you want to do that? Um,
there's this whole kind of way of
thinking. It's called, what's it called,
sovereignty to take some of
these documents as they exist,
they've got hooks in them.
So as I dug into this story,
I actually talked to a bunch of people who
the birth certificate seemed
like a paper of ownership
for political or religious
or just privacy reasons,
don't want this kind of documentation
from the government. Yeah,
definitely been used for
a measure of control.
Now faced parents who actually
wouldn't talk to me for this story,
they're not specifically
a part of that movement,
but my dad kind of adopted some of those
ideas that the government should not a
number assigned to us.
They purposefully raised faith and her
eight siblings to be outside of this
system and that's probably
something they thought of as a gift.
I guess the thinking is that faith
would be free from the rules of society.
Clearly my parents
did what they did out of like the best
that they thought they could do. So,
I mean I'm not going to get mad at anybody
for doing what they think they should
do. But to faith it
didn't feel like freedom.
It actually felt like prison. And this
is where faith journey really began.
Faith and her aunt and her
grandma, they went online,
started poking around and they realize
that the first thing you need is a birth
certificate. Yes, you're starting at
the beginning said, let's get you born.
Right. So she applied to the
bureau of vital statistics,
government office where they keep track
of like births, deaths, marriages,
adoptions, and the bureau of
vital statistics does a search,
not only of that name,
but of any like Jane Doe,
babies born in that area.
You know what to make sure that you
weren't stolen at birth from some other
parent or something like that.
But they couldn't find anything.
So they said the next
step is to go to court.
So my mom contacts the court and they
wanted three pieces of information proving
her birth facts. Well, there was
a sworn affidavit by my mother,
a swearing that, you know, she was
at her birth. So we got that one.
So they needed two more documents.
She could get a doctor's records,
but she doesn't have any,
I've never been at the hospital face
says she's never been that sick.
Never even had an accident
and never been to the dentist.
And you're flipping through
the no school records?
I had never even set foot inside of
school. Oh Wow. Any savings account?
No. You can't get a bank account without
a social. What about immunizations?
My Dad was super against all that.
One of the court clerks asked if she
had ever been baptized because the
certificate that you get when you're
baptized in a lot of churches can work as
one of the three pieces of evidence.
But it turns out the baptismal record
didn't have her birthday on it,
so it didn't count.
Did you ever go to the library
and get a library card? Nope.
You can't get a library
card without an ID.
Did you ever get any mail addressed to
your name at your parents' house? Yes,
but it was all, you know, handwritten
stuff, which doesn't count.
So you have to go to the judge and say,
what? What do you say to the judge?
Well, the judge won't
listen. He just said,
we're not going to hear the case because
you don't have enough to even for me to
even consider because you have
to have some kind of records.
You don't have enough proof.
So you're sitting there at a table and
there's a lawyer sitting there opposite
and you, and you think so.
So I know I was born. Uh,
I believe that I am this age.
I was born in my house at
such and such an address.
Now what do we do? He looks at you and
says, or she looks at you and says,
I've never seen this
before. She seen people,
well, undocumented,
but not someone born in this country
invisible to the state and the federal
government we put up, if
you're born in America,
you're not automatically a citizen.
So shouldn't that, I mean that.
It's not like when you're born there's
like this halo floating over your house.
Just letting everyone know you
have to prove it. Yeah. Were they,
couldn't she get a, an immigration
attorney to help? Won't, no, not really.
Because when an immigrant comes
here from another country,
they have this country of origin and
for faith in the eyes of the government,
she has no country of origin. They just
think of her as being from nowhere.
Wow. So I was just like,
I was stuck. That's weird.
We called everyone and we could not get
help and we'd get like a little bit of a
lead. Like maybe this will work.
And we'd go and we talked to
somebody or we fill out a paper,
we mail something yet or we
call somebody or something.
And just like you're rejected every
time, you know, it just looked hopeless.
It just made me feel like this is
never going to happen. You know,
it got to the point where when she was
at parties or just talking to people
about her situation,
there was like, oh, what are you
doing? I say, oh, I don't exist.
And it would kind of start this like
weird conversation and it would actually
start a lot of conversations
for other people.
And it would kind of help
me to like navigate stuff.
And so I actually kind of helped
me figure out how to socialize.
It's just this funny
little thing she could say,
but when she was alone
it wasn't funny at all.
I went through a really
dark time during that.
I went through a lot of depression. And
did your depression manifest in you?
What, what happened to you?
Um, I was not self harmful,
but I was having a lot of suicidal
thoughts. I feel me. Doesn't know.
Most of my friends don't even know.
It's just felt like I was just floating
in like in the middle of just see,
have just so much stuff, you
know, I didn't know who I was.
I kind of feel like I
didn't really exist at all.
[inaudible]
we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be right back.
Hello, this is Ricardo from
beautiful Monroe, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
that technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
when the legendary rapper prodigy died
after being hospitalized for sickle cell
anemia last year. His friends, his fans,
we're shocked in the summertime.
I know you're talking about this sunny
day right here that we have it right now.
Me and making beats Friday
g is dead right now.
I'm Mary Harris and I'm
Christopher Johnson.
The realness is a new
podcast from w NYC studios.
It takes you inside prodigies music and
asks why he couldn't escape a single
recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness
wherever you get your podcast.
Hey, I'm Jen. I boom, rod. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab and today
the story of a woman who famous for being
infamously invisible,
so she decided that the only solution was,
my name is Alicia Face Pennington
and I'm a u s citizen by birth.
To make this video,
I was born at home and my
parents neglected to file
birth certificate or birth
record of any kind. She just figured
I was homeschooled my entire life,
so I have no school records. Maybe
there's somebody out there that has,
you know, done this before, so I was
like, well, let's give it a shot.
I want to travel, I want
to get an education.
I wanted to just be a
functioning American,
but I can't until I can prove citizenship.
If you've been through a similar
situation or know anyone who can help,
please contact me. She put it up
on Youtube and then that was it.
[inaudible]
I didn't expect anyone to watch it
but
my phone was just like
notification after notification.
It was like dinging and dean and dean.
In the first week I had
over 1.3 million views.
I hadn't even like been on youtube before
that let alone like posted a video,
so it was crazy. It went up on Reddit,
Twitter and never seeing it on Yahoo in
the front of snapchat daily. Oh my gosh.
People just couldn't believe it. They
were like, can this seriously happen?
Gay just took off and then she just
starts getting all these emails.
It was insane. I was getting literally
two emails every single second.
That's not an exaggeration and
I couldn't keep up with it.
Like I could not read all of them coming
from like Germany and Israel, Africa,
Australia, India, like it went
worldwide. And what were people saying?
What did they email you
about? Oh, all kinds.
Like I was not only touched
by your screen presence,
but I'm also very infuriated and
frustrated by the circumstances of your
dilemma.
I actually sat down with faith while she
read through a bunch of these emails.
Hello. I'm very intrigued by your
story, but I'm currently 23 years,
some of them from homeschoolers.
Hello. Elisia my name is Jose.
I'm from the children of immigrants
who felt like a sense of solidarity.
I commend you for reaching out to
the Internet, but a lot of it was,
and I pray that you were able to get
the documents you need. Just a lot,
a ton of encouragement saying,
I don't know how to help you,
but I just want you to know I'm
rooting for you. Like don't give up.
What did it feel like to
have eyes on you in that way?
It was really empowering.
Um, like I didn't, I didn't,
it wasn't very confident in who I was. Um,
so just to have so many people
be like, we're behind you. Yeah.
I know. It felt really good
to be recognized a little bit,
but at the same time it kind of made
her more famously that woman who doesn't
exist,
the girl with no identity and it didn't
even solve her problem because when
people did offer advice didn't really
help start working on not paying tax.
They'll come to you. I got
people who just had, you know,
dumb ideas of what to do.
[inaudible] if I knew you enough to
marry you so you can gain citizenship.
Many of them were marriage proposals.
I got a lot of proposals. Uh,
actually I'll get you pregnant
if that will help. Oh my God,
that is some of them not
so subtle. Doesn't want to
just like delete. I'm like,
nope. Nope. And also inside
of those emails and comments,
there was a conversation about whether
what her parents did was right.
This one is from like
the opposite perspective.
It says her parents didn't quote neglect
anything. They stood on an exercise,
their rights, and wisely. So what
they did was in her best interest,
she just doesn't understand it because
she is young and she's led a protective
life.
A lot of these folks felt like faith was
blowing this gift that her parents had
given her.
From my perspective, if you take some
of these documents as they exist,
they've got hooks in them.
This is Alfred addict who blogs about
sovereignty and sovereign citizens.
First off, just to give
you a little bit of, uh,
evidence that maybe I'm not crazy.
There's a case called Chisholm
versus Georgia from 1793,
and they're talking about
European jurisprudence.
The distinction between
the prince and the subject.
And the distinction is that the
prince gets his rights from God.
That's when they say the
king is anointed. The Nice,
exactly right in a coronation ceremony.
But they go on and they say, no.
Such ideas obtained here, meaning
within the United States of America,
after the revolution, the
sovereignty devolved on the people,
and they are the true sovereigns.
And the word sovereigns is plural. Yeah.
I think we all know
that you're a sovereign.
I'm a sour and Alexandra's a sovereign.
How do you deal with the opening
phrase then in the constitution,
which is we the girl, we and
people, not I the person one by one,
but we the people want it says we the
people. It means we, the sovereigns.
Sovereigns are not a collective.
Think many people would argue.
I understand that. But if you are,
we ended up getting into this,
a little tussle over the rules
of government, not in visibility,
the idea that the constitution, but
eventually we got back to faith.
Once you have been recognized as
a sovereign, how do you avoid,
it's like getting rid, I'm doing
well. I'm just gonna. I want to judge.
I don't want blue eyes
anymore. But part of you must,
part of you must go out and feel a
little sorry for her. Right? Like she,
she's got, she has a,
she has a will to become something other
than he has a will to become a subject.
A subject. Yes. Yes. So,
but I don't think that you
condemning want to be free. Oh,
you are condemning her then? A little
bit. No, I'm saying she's making a choice.
There's proviso in the Bible
where people in the Old Testament,
if you wanted to remain, you could,
you could volunteer to
be a slave for some guy.
Some people don't want to be
sovereigns. It's not an email.
I just want a job and they want to
travel and they want to work for a little
bit. That's exactly right, but there's,
there are consequences for her abandoning
her status as a free woman. Well,
here's the weird irony because she has
no birth certificate because she has no
passport. The state of Texas in the
government or the United States say, well,
we can't figure out how to make you
visible like we, yeah, it's probably,
they may
not be able to,
but then face grandmother lives in
my district in Sun City and she,
the government stepped in.
My grandma was able to get
in touch with Marsha Farney,
Marsha Farney state representative
I of House district one.
She's a Republican member of the
Texas House of Representatives.
We would get together. I
do with my staff and say,
what are the calls we've
had come in this week?
And this one really caught our attention.
So usually heard about it. She said,
we need to do something
about this. And she did
this bill isn't as chimp to get
a birth certificate for those.
Around a month after her
face video went viral,
Marsha Ferny put together a bill
and brought it before the House of
Representatives in Austin.
The committee already read about
this bill and they are keenly aware.
So the bill does a couple of things.
It makes the process logistically easier
expanded where someone could apply for
a delayed birth certificate. It was,
but also outlines punishments for the
parents. So in the case of faith, right,
if she asked her parents for
documentation and they refused,
then that's punishable by up to a year
in jail and up to $4,000 of a fine or a
combination of both. Yeah.
Mr Chairman,
I know they are full of witnesses
here who want to testify on this bill
and they held this hearing to kind
of weigh the various sides. Hi,
I'm Alicia Southworth
live in Georgetown, Texas,
and I'm and so faith and her aunt
and her grandma all went to testify.
Faith is my granddaughter and my namesake.
I was in the room the day she was
born. Unfortunately that is not okay.
Her grandma fills in the state wraps
on what they'd been doing the last six
months.
We went to the DPS to get her a driver's
license and they said no. They said,
go to the social security
people. Security people said no.
Go to the voter registration people
meetings and dead ends and rejections.
No, go to the DPS. We
were stuck in a do loop.
Well, I wasn't gonna quit there
for goodness sake. She's a Texan.
So Marsha Farney has offered us our only
hope we have had since this started.
I just, I urge you to pass this bill,
take faith out of limbo and give
her the life she desires might be.
It was just like we would not allow my
parent to physically handicap a child.
We should not allow a parent to handicap
a child where they can't operate and
function in society. She is truly,
although you've seen her
standing here a nonperson,
she could walk off the face of the earth
and legally nobody would know she was
gone.
I think the bill is a little misguided.
That's James Pennington face dad.
He came out to the hearing and ended
up on the Fox seven newscast and
unfortunately this is the only
bit of tape we have of him.
He provides some pretty
draconian penalties for a
process. It's already there.
There are six other children, I
think. I don't disagree with that.
I mean just the state of Texas want to
put start putting parents jail. Well,
the bill gives the judge some leeway based
on what the circumstances are for the
parents, but we,
we felt there was a need for
some teeth to this bill to Ganda.
It turns out that the Texas State
House and State Senate agreed,
so we were able to get it
through the house and the Senate.
The bill ended up passing, Republicans
voted for it. Democrats voted for it.
There was actually only one, no vote,
but the next time Marsha for
any was up for reelection.
She actually lost in the primaries.
And according to the Texas observer who
actually did a really nice podcast of
face story,
there's this lobbying group called the
Texas homeschool coalition who donated a
bunch of money to Farnese primary
opponent who's parental
revenge I guess. Okay.
But then what, so where does your,
does that leave faith though?
Well, um,
because of the bill faith was able to
take her case to a different court,
a higher court,
and it seems like the bill allowed the
judge to consider different kinds of
evidence.
So in the end faith was able to use an
old orthodontist record and a piece of
paper from her uncle,
a doctor who had treated her
toe back when she was a kid.
And in just a couple of weeks,
success is the by certificate.
Sometimes I just take it out and
look at it sometimes randomly.
I know it's like, it's so dumb. It's
like it's your birth certificate.
Every person has one. But
I'm like, I have one too.
Can you read it to me a little bit? Like
what's, what information is on here?
Um, it has my name at the top and
it has like my description, my sex,
where I was born,
the county, just what county
does it say you're born in?
Harris County was born in Houston.
Ah.
I'm hoping that the physical papers can
like mirror the emotional thing that
she's going through because I feel like
it's like as she's getting the papers
she's appearing so that by the
time she gets that last one,
she will know who she is and then she
will be that person, whoever that is.
She's working so hard for it.
I'm hoping that that just that will
have developed in her something that she
feels like it's more than a piece
of paper, you know? Yeah. I'm hoping
so. Now faith, she was actually
able to get a driver's license,
but she still doesn't have her social
security number a which means she can't
get a real job. She can't open up
a bank account. She's still really,
she can vote, but she
can't get health insurance.
She might not be able to go to college,
so I don't know what's
going to happen to her.
We were asking her this question
like, when this is all over,
do you know who you're going to be? You
know, because now this is who you are.
You're the girl with no identity. And uh,
she was a little concerned that she
wouldn't know who she was going to be if
your, if your aunt asked you that
same question again, like who do,
who do you think you are now?
Who Do you think you are? No, I'm
[inaudible] what, how
would you answer that now?
Um, I don't know. Like
I just feel like me,
like I'm just faith.
Cool.
Cute. Thanks to recording
producer Alexandra young.
This piece is also produced by Brenna
feral and Andy Mills and we had a lot of
help from a lot of Texans, I should
say. Uh, I think they're mostly Texans.
Savannah Escobar, Rachel Komen, David
Glenn, Chris van Dusen, Zen Alegbra,
Russell Waylon, liberty
consultant, Nick Reed, the group,
homeschool alumni reaching out and the
Lake Travis Zip line adventure company.
Speaking of that last one, as you say,
when I went to go visit faith in Austin,
uh, she's got green hair now.
She's got a nose ring and a tattoo.
She goes home from time to time.
And she actually visited with her mom on
mother's Day. Um, but when I was there,
she wanted to do something with
me that she'd never done before.
I'm so excited you guys. So
we decided to go zip lining.
He said Zyban six,
and this one just happened to
be called the leap of faith.
Okay.
[inaudible]
yeah.
Hey, this is Jack. One last
thing before we close. Um,
I wanted to let you know that this
fall I'm actually going to be, uh,
doing something that I haven't done in
the 14 years that I have been working on
radio lab. I'm gonna take a little
time off. So, uh, you will not hear me,
uh, producing or hosting this
podcast through the fall.
I will be back early
January. Uh, and you know,
the reason is very simply that, you know,
in creating this show and then building
it up and then going on for live tours
and then most recently
creating the spinoff, our
first spinoff more perfect. Uh,
just need, I mean, it's
all been incredible,
but I just need a moment to catch my
breath and to reacquaint myself with my
children. So I'm going to be doing
that. But the great thing is that, um,
you know,
as much as Radiolab is this thing that I
started with Robert and with Ellen, um,
it's now as you know, home to a hugely
talented, amazing group of people. Uh,
so you'll be hearing more of them.
I mean, Robert, my partner in crime,
we'll be holding it down, but you'll
be hearing a lot more of Molly Webster,
a Soren, and a lot different.
Simon and the whole crew
will be doing stories.
And I happen to know there's some pretty
amazing stuff coming down the pike and
I, for one,
am really excited to be able to listen
to it from the outside for the first
time. So yeah, now we're making
a few appearances here and there.
So if you find yourself in like
Missoula, Montana or Sydney or Melbourne,
Australia, uh, come say, hey,
otherwise I will see you in the new year.